herzlich willkommen zu teil 2 von chemie
in der küche kurz vor weihnachten hatten
wir eine folge zu der chemie von
butterplätzchen und viele von euch
wollten einen teil 2 mit kuchen und das
machen wir jetzt
[Musik]
wir machen heute einen mann in
buttermilch kuchen und danach kommt
danach irgendwo stehen drauf aber es
geht erst noch die base um den kuchen
eine der wichtigsten eigenschaften bei
diesem kuchen ist seine flugfähigkeit
manches mal das heißt soll möglichst die
luft drin sein und es soll nicht
reserviert sind rot und es soll noch
nicht so dicht an ihn brown das erste
problem dass neil das ist ja wie basis
von dem kuchen aber mehr besteht nicht
nur aus kohlenhydraten sondern auch aus
proteinen darunter das böse zu themen
für die die sich vertragen aber deswegen
auch böse weil es das klever und ihn ist
das haben wir auch ohne in dem video
über kätzchen das gibt dem ganzen so
eine gewisse elastizität was wir beim
brot wollen aber bei so einem flüssigen
kuchen nicht deswegen habe ich hier so
genanntes prüfen ehe das gibt's manchmal
einem supermarkt kaum steht ein extra
drauf und es bedeutet dass im kuchen
mail weniger putin findet als er zum
beispiel in bodennähe die mutter ist
erst mal wichtig für den geschmack weil
sie das letzte video gesehen hat mit dem
kätzchen das kult entwickelt seine
tätlichkeit erst in kontakt mit wasser
und es hauptsächlich fett und mutter
dann auf diesen partikeln drauf liegt
dann stimmt es dass medizin vom wasser
ab das bedeutet die mehr butter drin ist
desto weniger kann dass putin seine
tätigkeit entfalten
hier haben wir ziemlich wie zucker ist
ein amerikanisches
sogar so natürlich erstmal für den süßen
geschmack das ist klar aber zucker ist
auch noch hygroskopisch das bedeutet
wasser an
wenn wir also den zuckergehalt
reduzieren wie der kuchen automatisch
auch trocken wenn wir den gleichen ofen
kommt wird er sogar noch besonders
wichtig das passieren zwei sachen
nämlich erstens die kanalisierung und
zweitens die auf diesem kanal
vielzitierte maja reaktionen die die
ganzen leckeren aromastoffen
hervorbringt wenn ihr öfters klagt
werdet ihr feststellen viele rezepte
fangen damit an dass man die butter mit
dem zucker schaumig schlägt das wären
wir gleich auch machen und zwar um ganz
viele luftbläschen reich zu bekommen für
den fluss zu lassen ihr so kleine
kristalle die wirtin dann wieso ich sage
kleine schleifsteine die dann helfen
beim schlagen die butter zu
durchschneiden und so besser die luft
rein zu kriegen natürlich sind auch ganz
wichtig beim backen das hatten wir schon
bei den mädchen in den einzeln proteine
drin
die sie damit anfangen so zusammengebaut
im ofen elf neulinge sich verlieren sich
zu einem netzwerk und bringen so die
ganze struktur denken in diesem rezept
haben wir drei eier und dann nochmal 3
eigelb gepard mehr fett als hat
meerwasser das fed hat also eine
ähnliche wird sowie bei der butter und
das wasser dehnt sich natürlich in dem
ruf einer nochmal aus der kuchen gleich
auf und bieten noch mehr flucht das
wichtigste für den fluss ist natürlich
backpulver bzw
backpulver nahrung sind nicht dasselbe
also in englischen rezepten ist das
beten dass ihr datings oder natron
rechnungs oder ist natrium
hydrogencarbonat wenn das mit säure
reagiert entstehen co2 gläschen geht auf
die haben die muttermilch muttermilch
ist sauer
das heißt wenn nachts mit buttermilch
reagiert in spezial 2 andre seine sachen
die man verwenden schokolade zb sauber
cacau was noch das reicht aber nicht als
flucht deswegen haben wir noch mal extra
backpulver dabei war die nato-flugzeuge
sollte es hier schon mit drin damit das
direkt reagiert und auf geht und dann
haben jetzt noch ein bisschen sei es
auch für geschmack und ein bisschen
vanille exakt ich habe mir viel stärker
geholt das ist christine dies auch
chemiker in den zweikämpfen besser als
eine und zusam ideenlos
[Musik]
das rezept ist für 20 cent was du gesagt
20 bis 27 jahren bis hier ist schon
einiger so pierre quadrat kaliber was
über nicht dass es dann irgendwie zu
flachen wir keine schöne torte mit
ausmachen
ich habe noch so ein
[Musik]
da kann was heute der kann der boden
wurde das vorstellen das konzept gibt es
unten in der infobox mit allen anderen
infos gebrauchen könnten wenn ihr diesen
kuchen zb eure mama zum muttertag fragen
wollt könnt ihr das gerne tun wenn er
einfach mal fünf stunden zeit gefahr für
den kürzesten buchen erstellen das war
schlau abonniere nicht vergessen